[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضرتكم مساء الخير مع
الدكتور حمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك
كتير كتير
من الناس في الفتره الاخيره وهو موضوع
الهيدروجين
الهيدروجين كمصدر بديل عن الطاقه
الاحفوريه لكن لما طرحت السؤال على
الدكتور يسري ابو شادي فقلت ان المساله مش
هيدروجين ازرق ولا رمادي ولا اخضر اللي هو
طبعا اهم وقود بنتكلم عليه ده ليه الوان
كثيره وقصه كبيره في موضوع حلقتنا
النهارده نفهم ايه قصه الهيدروجين وهل
يمكن ان يكون بديل فعال عن الوقود
الاحفوري اللي بيهدد الكره الارضيه بمزيد
من التلوث
واستثماراته والتك اللي مستثمره في الى
اخره معالي الدكتور السؤال الاول خالص ايه
قصه الهيدروجين ده دي طاقه جديده على
الكره الارضيه ولا هي مستخدمه تمام سؤال
جميل ونقول هو ايه اللي طلع الهيدروجين في
الاعلام بالشكل الكبير لفترات الاخيره ديت
فنقول ببساطه شديده يعني انتم كلكم
بتسمعوا عن
الاحتباس الحراري اللي موجود في الارض
وزياده درجه الحراره والمشاكل الكبيره جدا
اللي ممكن تؤدي الى زياده درجه الحراره
لدرجه ان ممكن بعض الدول وبعض الجزر تختفي
تماما بسبب ارتفاع الحراره دي بسبب طبعا
همم
ميلتينج بتاع همم قطب ذات القطب الجنوبي
ولا قطب الشمالي والتالي والميه ارتفاع
المستوى الميه همم ما بين اثنين متر 5 متر
الى تختفي بعض البلاد اذا احنا عندنا
مشكله طب الاحتباس الحراري ده جاي منين
جاي من باعاشات ثاني اكسيد الكربون جايه
منين ثاني الكربون من 200 سنه بدا التوازن
البيئي في الارض يتغير ما بين دائما كان
همم بلاس ماينس ومعادل نفسه همم ما فيش
تغير في درجه الحراره تقريبا الدلتا
بتاعته دي اللي هي سكر لكن من 200 سنه
بدات الثوره الصناعيه وبدات استخدام
الطاقه بصوره خاصه الفحم والبترول بعدها
همم ودولا كلها همم مصادر همم انبعاث كبير
جدا لسانه كثير كربون طب ثاني اكسيد
الكربون ده بيعمل ايه لما بيطلع في الجو
العادي بتاعنا اللي هو في البيئه بيؤدي
الى همم عدم انعكاس اشعه الشمس يعني اشعه
الشمس تنزل على سطح الارض وتجيء تنعكس حسب
القوانين الطبيعيه بتاعتها ثاني اكسيد
الكربون يمنع
الانعكاس بتاع الشمس همم مره اخرى للخارج
طيب نلاقي ان هو بيحبس الطاقه الشمسيه ده
هي يحسبها على سطح الارض يؤدي لايه يؤدي
ارتفاع درجه الحراره طب حصل ايه خلال ال
200 سنه اللي فاتت درجه الحراره زادت
بمقدار 1.2 لحد 20 20 طب لو الكيرف بتاع
لو تشوفه يعني منحنى زياده درجه الحراره
تلاقي المنحنى التصاعدي شديد جدا لدرجه
انه هيوصل الى اكثر من درجتين على نهايه
هذا القرن طيب لو استمر هذا همم زي ما قلت
لكم هيحصل مشاكل
رهيبه اذا انا محتاج اوقف ثاني اكسيد
الكربون اللي هو بينتج بصوره اساسيه من
مصادر عديده اهمها الطاقه
الكوري وبصوره خاصه همم الفحم او الكرب-
يعني اه
البترول والغاز الطبيعي دول اهم المصادر
الطاقه اللي بيتحوله
اذا انا عايز اغير من اسلوبنا في الطاقه
بدور على طاقه نظيفه طيب هنا بقى نيجي
ندور هو فين مصادر الطاقه نظيفه المصادر
الاساسيه زي ما احنا عارفين شمس الرياح
النووي دول لا يمكن اهم مصادر للطاقه
النظيفه طيب انا عندي مشاكل الشمس دي ما
بتشتغلش اليوم كله الرياح همم برده بتروح
وتجيء همم انا النهارده لما باعمل عربيات
الكهرباء بنهايه باشحن الكهرباء في
البطريات العاديه دهيت من خلال كهربه جايه
من محطه بترول ولا فحم ولا غاز طبيعي ولا
ايه طيب يبقى انا كده ما ال- ال- العربيات
الكهرباء مثلا ما حلت لي جزئيه مشكله
التلوث همم لان في الشوارع طبعا هيبقى
العربيه نظيفه العربيه الكهرباء لكن الشحن
البطاريات وشحن العربيات الكهربيه جايه من
مصادر ملوثه للبيئه طيب هل ممكن ان انا
اغير المصادر الاهتمام
دي الهيدروجين ليه الهيدروجين لان
الهيدروجين مصدر
العادم بتاعه الميه يعني لما بحرقه بيتحد
مع الاكسجين
ان انا اعمل هيدروجين فكره جميله جدا طيب
انا بعمل بقى الهيدروجين
عده مصادر يا اما مثلا اجيبه عن طريق
سوائل فحم او الغاز الطبيعي او الميثان
اللي هو سي اتش 4 ده الميثان انا ممكن
منتج الهيدروجين الهيدروجين مش موجود في
الهواء تقريبا يقترب من السفر لكن هو
موجود كان مركب موجود في الميه البحار
موجود فيه بعض المركبات همم في الصخور في
الارض في الحاجات المختلفه دي تشكل ما
يخرج من ثلثين الماده بتاعه الكره الارضيه
دي لا هو الهيدروجين اذا هو موجود بكثره
متوافر لكن الهيدروجين غاز الغاز نفسه مش
موجود بكثره اذا لازم انتجه هنتجه بقى
ازاي نجيء بقى نشوف الطرق يا اما ان انا
باسخن المواد ده هي اللي هي في غاز
الطبيعي او الفحم او بتاعه وعدي عليها
مثلا بخار ماء ساخن او بتاع واحللها الى
هيدروجين وكربون ال- ال- وبالتالي اطلع
الهيدروجين لكن المشكله لا هو طلعه من
المياه او بطريقه هو طلعه من التحليل
الكهربائي من الميه او ادور في بعض الباطن
الارض في الصخور الحاجات دي بس ضعيفه وبعد
كده بقى بيسموا الالوان طيب اذا هي
المساله بمنتهى البساطه
العالم بيبحث عن مصادر الطاقه
اللي موجوده ملوثه للبيئه وبالتالي وجد
ضالته في الهيدروجين اللي هو مش موجود
بشكل يذكر فيه الطبيعه ولكن هو مكون
من مكونات المياه ومكون في بعض مصادر
الطاقه الاخرى او المواد الكيميائيه
الاخرى او حتى في بعض المواد الموجوده في
باطن الارض زي الميثان الى اخره وبالتالي
بيتم فصله واستخدامه كمصدر للطاقه مظبوط
معاه الدكتور هنا يتبقى السؤال بما انه هي
دي مصدر مكون وبيتم فصله عندنا مجموعه من
الاسئله احنا بنسمع عن الوان للهيدروجين
الهيدروجين الازرق الهيدروجين الرمادي
الهيدروجين الاخضر وسمعنا عن همم
الى اخره يعني همم ده معناه ان دي بتشير
الوان رمزيه الى مصدر الهيدروجين اللي
بيتاخذ منه المصدر الهيدروجين بيتاخذ منه
طيب قبل ما نتكلم على انواع الهيدروجين
نقول هو الهيدروجين انا عايزه اعمل به ايه
العايدروجين همم اهم سبب وجود وتخليق
الهيدروجين انه مصدر للطاقه نظيفه زي ما
قلنا انا ممكن باحرقه وباديني بيطلع لي
طاقه وبعدين الفضلات بتاعته هو انه بيطلع
ميه فاذا هو مصدر طاقه نظيف كطاقه نفسها
ممكن يطلع لي كهرباء همم ممكن يعمل لي
هيتينج لبيوت
الجزء الثاني الهام قوي انه بيستخدم في
وسائل النقل عربيات في بطاريات بتشتغل
بالهيدروجين بتطلع همم كهرباء البطاريه
بتاعتها لو خالته مع الليثيوم ممكن تقعد
15 سنه وده اللي بينتجوه دلوقت همم وهو
الحقيقه كانت موجوده البطاريات الهيدروجين
الليثيوم دي من سنين طويله كانت بتستعمل
في
ستالايت وفي المركبات اللي هي بتعيش كثير
برده في الفضاء هو كانت موجوده
همم
لانه كان غرضه استراتيجي اكثر منه همم اذا
همم في همم يعني اهميه الطاقه
دين الطاقه ودي نقطه من اهم النقط انه كان
بيجيء اوقات كثيره زي الطاقه الشمسيه انا
ما عنديش شمس وبالتالي انا عايز مصدر
للطاقه المستمره اللي عايز انت الكهرباء
مستمره 24 ساعه فباجيء اخذ جزء من الطاقه
ديت اطلع بيه هيدروجين واجي بالليل مثلا
اروح مشغل البطاريات الهيدروجين دهيت تطلع
لي كهرباء وتستمر
طاقه من الرياح اه الرياح سيد مثلا ال-
ال- التربونات بتشتغل بالليل انت حضرتك
بتقول ان نفس الطاقه دي اللي بتشتغل
بالليل ممكن تستخدم لتوليد الهيدروجين
وبالتالي الهيدروجين يتم تخزينه في
بطاريات والبطاريات تشتغل بقى يعني على
طول بالضبط
ما تشوفوش يعني غير ملون ولا غير مجهز ان
انت تعرف في حاجه هو الهيدروجين غاز غير
سام يعني بالمناسبه الهيدروجين غاز ده
ممكن يبقى سائل ممكن لو عند بس ناقص 250
درجه مئويه ممكن تحول الى همم ميه زي زي
سائل يعني ممكن يستخدم زي الغاز بشكله
الغازي او بشكل سائل سائل زي ما بنشر
الغاز الطبيعي ما بنحوله للسائل عشان
تسهيل النقل والحجم بتاعه يبقى اصغر يعني
همم
دين وسائل المختل- ده الهيدروجين بقى ودي
مواصفاته نجيء بقى امال ايه حكايه ال همم
لغه
ناس كثير يمكن متخيله ان الهيدروجين ده
لونه صحيح اخضر ولا لونه ازرق
كده في الجوجل هيبص هيلاقي في 10 الوان
مختلفه بيتكلموا فيها هيدروجين ده زي ما
حضرتك قلت ده كلام مجازي يعني ما هواش
حقيقي لكن هو قاعد
ايرا عن التاثير البيئي لهذا الهيدروجين
ومصادر تكوينه واستخدامه احنا متفقين
دلوقت ان هيدروجين ده مصدر نظيف للطاقه
لكن المصادر اللي بتنتج الهيدروجين دي
متشكله بقى لها انواع مختلفه دي ممكن ملوث
وممكن غير ملوث اسوا واحد فيهم اللي هو
بيسموه الهيدروجين الاسود ده اللي طالع من
الفحم النباتي اللي هو الفحم العضوي زي
الشجر والاكل والحاجات ديت ده اكثر واحد
بيطلع شنب كربون وبالتالي هو التلوث
الاقصى عشان كده سموه اسود في بني في
الوقت الحالي
اه كان بيوتك طبعا بصوره خاصه في الصين هي
كانت بتنتج كثير لانه كان موجود ورخيص قوي
ده ارخص انواع الفحم حلو جدا ارخص انواع
الهيدروجين الفحم اولا اللي طبعا هيطلع
هيدروجين رخيص طيب تمام
الاسود اللي بيجي من الفحم النباتي وعندنا
الهيدروجين
فحم الحجري فحم الحجري هو الفحم اللي
موجود في المناجم في الصخور في الحاجات دي
هي تمام ده قيمته اكثر شويه واغلى
وبالتالي همم برده استخداماته حسب
الاقتصاديات لكن يقدر يطلع بيطلع منه
هيدروجين بيسموه بني قبل باتكلم على
هيدروجين الاخضر في همم عندنا انواع ثانيه
زي الهيدروجين مثلا انواع ثاني من الالوان
البني الفحم الحاجه دي ال- الرمادي واللي
هو منتشر تقريبا ممكن اكثر
على العالم ده بينتج من الغاز الطبيعي
والمثال من المنتجات البترول يعني البترول
والغاز الطبيعي والمثال همم بعد الدوله
بيطلعوا الكل الثلاثه اللي فاتوا دول كلهم
بيطلعوا عشان اكسيد الكربون في الجو كده
زي ما انت بنسبه عاليه جدا لو انا حطيت
فلاتر قويه جدا تمتص
ثاني اكسيد الكربون ده هي وما تطلعوش او
تقللوا
الدعاس بتاعه في الجو همم في الحاله دي
انا وبعد كده اتخلص منه بطريقه كيماويه او
بطريقه اخرى بيسميه همم الهيدروجين الازرق
لو انا يعني مناعه زي ما هو بس طبعا ما
باقدرش امنعه فقط
لان السعر كمان لو يجي هنتكلم عن السعر
السعر همم تدريجيا بيزيد حسب اللون يعني
ارخصهم زي ما قلت الاسود ثم البني همم ثم
الروماني ثم الازرق الازرق اغلس شويه يعني
اذا كنا بنتكلم على ان الكيلو جرام
الهيدروجين همم من همم وقود الاحفوري ده
هو بيبقى بيتراوح بحدود من واحد الى اثنين
دولار همم لكل كيلوغرام الازرق من ثلاثه
لاربعه يعني ممكن ضعف عشان طبعا تكاليف
ال- كلاتر همم
وتخزين
الكربون ده اهو همم نجيء بقى بعد كده طيب
هو همم ما فيش بقى غير كده همم عايزين بقى
نوصل الى الاخضر طب ما اقول لو انا المصدر
بتاع انتاج الهيدروجين ده هيكون من همم
طاقه نظيفه من الاصل نرجع بقى نقول هو ايه
بقى مصادر الطاقه الشمسيه همم طاقه همم
رياح مساقط الميه
دول اثارهم يعني
المصادر دي كلها لو انا هو ده كلهم لا
ينتج عنهم ثاني اكسيد الكربون وبالتالي ما
فيش حاجه اسمها احتباس حراري بالنسبه لك
لو هما دول استعملتهم طلعوا كهربا انت
قولي
هيدروجين بطريقه التحليل الكهربي التحليل
الكهربائي ده هي دي طريقه غير ملوثه هي
ميه وباجيب قطبين كهربائيين يمكن معظم
الناس عارفه اخذوا التجربه دي وهم في
المدارس همم من القطب
والنيجاتيف
طبعا الهيدروجين هيروح للنيجاتيف الثانيه
الاكسجين
وهكذا بحيث ان نبصل الهيدروجين بطريقه
نظيفه من غير غير ملوثه ده مصدر الكهرباء
اللي انا باستعمله ملوش ولا الميه اللي
انا باحللها بالطريقه دي ملوثه ده بيسموه
الهيدروجين الاخضر وبالتالي العالم كله
نفسه يوصل لهذا طب ليه العالم
التقفيل هذا ببساطه شديده لانه سعره
الحالي يتقتل 10 دولار يمكن من 10 ل 15
دولار خلي بالك احنا تكلمنا دلوقت من واحد
الى اربعه اللي هو الهيدروجين اللي اقل ده
مره واحده بينط هات طب وانا اقدر ارخص ده
اه ممكن ارقص ده ازاي ارقص ده عن طريق
ترخيص مصدر الكهرباء نفسه اللي بيطلع
الشمسيه والطاقه الهوائيه الى اخرى
اذا تطورت التكنولوجيا اكثر وبقيت ارخص
وبتستخدم على نطاق واسع تبقى ارخص
وبالتالي اقدر اطلع منها الهيدروجين
الاخضر الحقيقه هو موضوع يعني كذاب جدا
ويستحق ان احنا نخسس له حلقات ثانيه بس
انا عندي سؤال صغير بالمره لانه الناس
هيسالوني الالوان التانيه سريعه جدا جدا
احنا وصلنا دلوقتي الى الاسود البني
الرمادي الازرق الاخضر تمام
مصدر الكهرباء اللي جاي من الطاقه الشمسيه
والرياح وما بين منظر الكهرباء اللي جايه
من النووي والحقيقه الاثنين غير ملوثين
ولا يصدر عنهم ثاني اكسيد الكربون فسموه
واحد سماه هو الحله التي ما فيش تعريف
رسمي
اللي هو البمبي والثاني يسميها الاصفر اه
اللي هي التسميه بعض الناس سموا انه
الهيدروجين اللي بيتم توليده باستخدام
الطاقه النوويه بالبنك
واحد مره قالوا بمبي وردي
يعني همم اصفر هل فيه الوان ثانيه في همم
همم
ممكن تطلع من مصر من همم الارض في لو انت
طلعت الهيدروجين ده من الارض هو بيشكل
يمنع انك تخزن ثاني اكسيد الكربون اللي
طالع معه همم في همم مخازن قويه ومغلقه
بحيث ايه ده ده بيسميه اللي هو الابيض
في ناس ثانيه بتعرف لا ده فيه هيدروجين
ثاني انا بجيبه من البلاستيك ومن الفضلات
العضويه لو انا يعني خلصت الناس من
الفضلات بتاعتها ومن البلاستيك ده انا
اقدر
خاصه البلاستيك لان بلاستيك ده موجود فيه
مواضع عضويه فيها الهيدروجين فيها الكربون
طب الكربون اعمل فيه ايه اعمله برده اخزنه
في مخازن نفس الكلام اللي قبل كده لكن
الميزه بقى هنا دي على كربون ولا
الهيدروجين
الكربون الثاني
طب ما هو ده شبيه بالازرق اقول لك لا يفرق
عن الازرق في ايه
انهيد
الكربون اللي طالع ده هو
انا
يعطي تلوث من الفضلات دي انا محتاجها انا
هتخلص منها ازاي فانا بتخلص منها بانتج
منها هيدروجين
وفي نفس الوقت بخزن ال ثاني اكسيد الكربون
لحد ما اعرف اتخلص منه بطرق مختلفه يعني
فده سموه بقى تركواز
فيروزي حاجات كده يعني في يمكن 10 الوان
مختلفه يعني بس هو لا لونه ولا طعم له
عشان ما حدش الوان
اذا الخلاصه معالي الدكتور انه الهيدروجين
اصبح الحديث كثير عليه باعتباره مصدر جيد
جدا بديل غير ملوث للبيئه بديلا عن الوقود
الاحفوري للعالم عاوز يقلص استخدامه منه
وانه ده مش موجود في الطبيعه وبالتالي هم
بيستخلصوه من مصادر مختلفه اهمهم المياه
او بعض مصادر الوقود الاحفوري الى اخره
وانه الالوان المختلفه اللي بتسمى
بالهيدروجين الازرق اخضر على حسب المصدر
اللي هي تم منه او الطريقه اللي هيتم بها
توليد الهيدروجين اهمهم واللي احنا العالم
كله بينشط انه يعتمد عليه هو الهيدروجين
الاخضر لانه هو بيتم توليده وليكن من
المياه ولكن الطريقه اللي بيتم توليده بها
باستاذ تستخدم فيها تكنولوجيا او مصدر
طاقه نظيف تحديدا الهمم الشمس او الرياح
وده بيفسر لنا ليه بعض الدول المتقدمه
بتحاول ان هي
تستورد الوقود الاخضر ده والهيدروجين
الاخضر
من دول ناميه زي دول الشرق الاوسط لان
عندها قدره كبيره جدا على توليد الطاقه من
الرياح ومن الطاقه الشمسيه فدي ميزه كبيره
جدا للدول المنطقه اللي هي غنيه بالشمس
على وجه التحديد وطبعا بعض مساقط الرياح
همم اللي بيمنعنا او بيمنع العالم على انه
يعتمد بشكل كبير جدا على الهيدروجين الان
التكلفه اللي هي بتبقى مرتفعه مع اي
تكنولوجيا جديده ثم تنخفض مع الوقت مضبوط
معنا الدكتور تمام انا عايز بس اضيف حاجه
صغيره ان في تطبيق هام جدا بيهم جدا ان
الدول العربيه بصوره خاصه دول عربيه
الصحراويه ان همم عن طريق انتاج
الهيدروجين وتخزينه وممكن تسييله حتى انا
ممكن انقل مصدر الطاقه ده لاي حته اي
منطقه نهائيه لا محتاج لشبكه كهرباء ولا
بتاع هو مين هناك انا ممكن اعمل كل حاجه
ممكن انت الكهرباء ممكن اعمل همم ممكن
اطلع هيدروجين زي العربيات ممكن اعمل اا
منطقه اجتماعيه كامله باستخدام الهيدروجين
ده فهو مفيد جدا في المناطق الصحراويه
ومناطق النائيه يعني ملحوظه بس اخيره لان
انا واثقلت تعليقات عليها اعتبار الطاقه
النوويه بمصدر نظيف للطاقه محل خلاف شويه
انا عارف راي حضرتك على اعتبار ان هو صحيح
لا يولي الثاني اكسيد الكربون لكن في
مخلفات نوويه باحتاس العالم في تخزينها
بعد كده فهي الافضل ان احنا لو اعتمدنا
شويه في تصنيف الطاقه النظيفه على الشمس
والريحه مظبوط معنا الدكتور همم نص مضبوط
ههه
نقطه واحده في الطاقه النوويه اللي هي
معلقه اللي هو السبنج في الوقود المستهلك
بتاعه لحد الان ما عنديش وسيله همم مثاليه
لتخزين هذا الوقود لكن في النهايه حجم
الوقود ده قد ايه همم مستودع مبنى صغير
كده باحط فيه الحاويات اللي فيها الوقود
ل100 او 200 سنه
لحد ما انا جبت حالي يعني جزير الشكل
العام للدكتور وشكرا لحضراتكم وطبعا لو في
مزيد من الاسئله عن الهيدروجين او مصادر
الطاقه الاخرى استاذنكم ان تكتبوا الينا
ااا اكرر شكرا على الدكتور مره ثانيه والى
لقاء اخر باذن الله